[Applause]
yeah so you know I was thinking a cat
warm in the spring clean but let's hear
it for Tuesday's tater tot day yeah my
touch recalled no tops
my body can't process potatoes also
painting turnips or yams or tubers I'm
also a chicken
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
any other tribe hi primal kill me I love
pie
so then I told Ultron go ahead and
destroy it I got five more Bentley's at
home phony man till these dog really
funny stuff Tony
sorry bad boy this table is marble only
yeah D see you later dude guys DC Marvel
what's the difference
have you check the box office lately
[Applause]
okay right I get it
Marvel's kicking DC's ass right now okay
who knew people like superheroes having
fun instead of superheroes being sad and
tortured and always soaked in the rain
yeah why is it was raining Batman is
Gotham City in Seattle the rain we just
join you guys but there's an empty seat
right there
you know what sure go ahead just move my
hammer yes thank you for the best glue
to the chair something maybe you've got
some muscles on your utility though
I'll cut to the chase
picture this The Avengers featuring
Batman you really want to switch sides I
mean what about all your cool DC buds
over there yeah see that's a jellyfish
boner look those guys are a huge tract
they're not fun like us yeah you're a
real party animal don't you live in a
cave filled with bat turds
it's called guano and you know why I
live there because my parents were
murdered everyone knows your origin
story and that's happened like 14 years
ago get over it yeah my dad died and I
beat up the Hulk like the next day what
does Batman even bring to the table that
means a great fighter oh thanks but I've
already got that cover no offense
Black Widow but news flash you're a
yes oh please don't let me go back to
that table I have so much timber
come on having the Dark Knight join
Marvel is a win-win seriously name one
thing about Batman that isn't totally
cool
apparently they have like six dicks oh
my god would you look at this guy he
looks like mr. incredible with
alcoholism
is the last to hide your identity or do
you wear it out of shame you look like a
Rubik's Cube made a wish to become a
little boy you marvel guys think you're
so great but I mean come on like you
blondie you make good tips at medieval
times and you is there an S&M spin class
that needs teaching somewhere and look
here Richie Rich bought himself an
iPhone case that he can wear you are
wearing a kitty cat costumes
the Fantastic Four sucked
[Applause]
universe what an [ __ ] let's do this
what do you say how do we make it happen
right sign the contract or something
let's get it done
[Applause]
these the dentin it's not even the
Riverdale
great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you